good wednesday was a significant day for
the national football league because it
was the day that the owners voted on
rule changes for 2021. many
failed but some passed and the one that
passed
is the half measure that i hate chris
the expanded duties of the replay
assistant
now on top of everything else the replay
assistant already does the replay
assistant
will have some involvement
in fixing
objective rulings that are clearly and
obviously wrong by communicating
directly with the on-field staff
the league office through alberon
already has some responsibility when it
comes to administration of rules and
that's part of what this expansion is
for the replay assistant there was some
confusion earlier this week about where
the lines were between the replay
assistant's expanded duties and what
al river on already does i just don't
like it because
they need to go the rest of the way i've
said this time and again let me just say
it one more time not that i won't say it
again after that
there is a gap between what the seven
people on the field see
and what the millions who are watching
at home or wherever else they get their
nfl content
c they need an official a member of the
crew
who sees what we see and communicates
with the officials
and as the ravens said when they
proposed it this year
yeah one of these days we're gonna have
it
why not have it now right i mean like
i'm with you all the way
let me get this straight like are they
talking like they're gonna put more
on al riveron's plate here with this no
no
no the replay assistant who's there okay
stadium who
who's responsible for activating replay
review i just wanted to make situations
where it's automatic it's the person
who's already there
yes who's like the liaison between now
river on and the referee
that person now has extra duties and i
had someone who understands the
functions of the officiating department
very well tell me a few weeks ago
yeah the replay assistant's already busy
enough and
this isn't going to work because of that
and they need to go the rest of the way
but for whatever reason the nfl's
officiating department isn't on board
with having that booth umpire that sky
judge that extra person i still don't
understand why i don't get that either
this this is going to save you from the
next
ram saints debacle why wouldn't you want
to do whatever you have to do
to save yourself from another nightmare
scenario and i think they just assume
shereen williams and i were talking
about this last night on pfdpm i think
the powers that be
just assumed lightning is not going to
strike again in their lifetimes or at
least during the times they're in the
position to have to worry about it
well let the next crop or the next one
after that or the next one after that
deal with the next time something like
that happens yeah i mean i guess so it
does seem to be an odd approach
i don't know why you'd want to throw you
know more work
on somebody that's you know pretty busy
already why wouldn't you want an extra
pair of eyes
to be there to look over everything who
can kind of just
like you said help everybody out i i
really don't i don't i don't get that i
would think it would make the game
smoother just to have one more guy
communicate whatever it is but
what is holding them back from just
doing that i i don't
i don't understand it mike you've been
banging the drum for this for ever since
the saints rams game
and um i i i didn't like love it at
first but
the more we've talked about it and
discussed it like i think you're totally
right
i do and there's always things that need
to be cleaned up during football games
or whatever
else and that's where i would go like i
you know
like i i guess what are the expanded
duties like what that's where
like where i i'm like what what's the
big change about this here
what exactly do they mean by all this
what's the nut and bolts of all this i i
guess i'm a little confused by exactly
what we're saying here with the rule
change
the language is that the replay official
will advise the on on-field officials
with specific objective aspects of a
play when clear and obvious video
evidence is present and that means
did the receiver get two feet down yeah
was the ball
out was the receiver in bounds or out of
bounds specific
objective there won't be okay the
ability
technically technically there won't be
the ability for the replay assistant
to say oh it looks like there was pass
interference on that play looks like
nikhil roby-coleman blew up tommy lee
lewis you better throw a flag right
technically they won't have the ability
to do that now anyone who's watched this
show for more than a little while and
if you have we appreciate it i i'm a
firm believer that's going to happen to
break the rules
yeah no but but do it do it and look al
riveron could have done it
in that ram saints game could have done
it and i'm told
per sources with knowledge of the
situation he specifically decided not to
do it because it would have been against
the rules
right sometimes you got to have the
foresight sometimes you got to have the
understanding
the creativity of imagination to say you
know what
it's gonna be a gigantic mess for a lot
of people for a long time
i'm gonna get on the horn and i'm gonna
tell the referee
drop a flag what do you mean drop a flag
just trust me drop a flag you'll thank
me later drop a flag
drop a flag what we never had this
conversation yeah drop a flag right
right yeah i mean well like in all
seriousness and how many times have we
talked about this on sundays or even a
monday show
i mean come on it's been going on ever
since that happened
you know the old hey and before and
before
right oh huddle up as the eff yeah the
huddle up the officials and they sit
there and they look at the big screen
and then
you know one of them has something in
the yeah their ear and it's
yeah oh yeah but yeah dj played that
other song again right
now not exactly you're listening to al
rivera i mean come on
so i guess you know it's a good thing
from this standpoint just at a base
level
it it's gonna save some teams probably
some challenges
right and things like that during the
game and maybe just speed up the process
of the game
a little bit uh to the point where we
don't have those stoppages where it's
like
what the receiver got to feed in and how
did the
how did the how did the official miss
that
and then if that's when this replay
official comes in and goes
hey wait wait he he got him in you know
go change the call in the field
completion completion
i'm all for that i really am because it
would be
a pain in the butt one you know to go to
now we gotta throw the flag stop the
game go to commercial break and do
all that and then of course you only
have so many challenges in your pocket
as it is as a coach anyway so i guess it
saves that department and i like that
but go the rest of the way yeah i'm with
you there's one of the great
monologues from mike airman trout's
character
or what the character was mike cameron
jonathan banks is the actor who
portrayed him in breaking bad the
explanation of why you don't engage in
half measures you go
the full way and chris you may not
remember this the week of the super bowl
following that ram saints debacle
heading into super bowl
53 we had
was it 53 it was 50 yeah we had rich
mckay the chair of the competition
committee with us on site because the
game was being played in atlanta and
they do that victory lap we got the
super bowl
we got a new stadium and it was
obvious to me he had no interest in
doing
anything about the rules in the
aftermath of that game his attitude was
stuff happens yeah right or a word with
one fewer letter happens and we'll just
deal with it when it does
but this is a once in a hundred year
event
and we can deal with it and then when
when they had the rule change forced
down their throats like they did because
the competition committee went to the
league meetings that year
with no proposal to do anything
meaningful to fix what happened
in the ram saints game the owners and
the coaches and the executives decided
we're going to have
replay review for past interference
calls and non-calls yeah then it ends up
being a disaster
yeah to the point where now you are
reluctant to do anything
significant because you're you're a
little bit gun shy
from what happened with the last one
because of all the
unintended consequences and and that
hope that whole
that whole unintended consequences crap
that's just an excuse for having failure
of imagination
how hard is it to get into a room and
brainstorm
all the stuff that could go wrong if we
do this
and if you don't have people in the room
smart enough to identify all the stuff
that could go
wrong when you change a rule people who
supposedly know the game inside and out
you need smarter people in the room
because it ain't all that hard
to make unintended consequences expected
consequences
so you don't do the thing that you're
going to do and
how hard would it have been chris for
someone to realize you know there's a
chance given the issues we've had with
replay review in the past
all due respect and what's a catch
what's not a catch and
the the standards all over the place
right there's a chance there's a chance
we do this the guy who's responsible all
due respect is gonna be all over the
place with that too
so either we don't do it or we dig deep
we we maybe give uh give that guy that
left for fox a phone call and get him to
come back and be the one to do it you
know
it didn't all that hard you didn't know
that hard to figure out what you need to
do and chris that's that's i made that
jump
earlier yeah it's money they don't want
to pay you don't have to pay the replay
assistant anymore to say hey you know
what you're going to have more duties
how many people walk into work on a
given day and find out they got more
duties and getting paid any more money
for it yeah
you you have 17 sky judges
yeah you have to pay money salaries i
know and they don't want to do it yeah
17 more members of the union i think 17
more of this
it's shocking more plane tickets yeah i
i know which is like you know i
i mean i understand it's expensive but
it's not i mean come on that's that's
it's a drop in the bucket it's nothing
it's like it's it's no
nothing as compared to what the league
is making and
keeping the integrity of the game you
know where it should be
all that you know mike i mean i really i
think it's only a matter of time before
the sky judge happens maybe this is just
like
the first step to make that happen and
the the point you always bring up that
at least rings true to me
you know this is the legalized gambling
i mean again that that's real
you're right it's it's another aspect
that i think it'll make gamblers feel
better if there's that guy there this
will make them feel better too
my big thing with this just a little bit
is like the guy's got a lot on his plate
all of that stuff like you've already
said but you know also within the
uh clear and obvious it just it
i don't know we to me it's it's been
pretty proven that we don't know what
clear and obvious is all the time either
so i guess that's my other issue with
this and i just i want to see the
mechanics of this exactly how it works
um i don't think it's a you can look
huge change but
you know it's a good one at least and
maybe a start down the right road for
for your
sky judge you've got 17 replay
assistants who very well may be inclined
to punt
to al river on and let him decide via
replay review
that there there was clear and obvious
and that's where things are going to get
a little bit screwy because
the replay review when it happens that
would happen
after the replay assistant chimes in so
let me just give you an example i'm
trying to
articulate this on the fly it may work
it may not at least i admit it in
advance
but let's say there's a close
call on a catch okay
and on the field
no catch right replay assistant gets
involved
replay assistant decides catch
well when al riveron activates the
replay review whether there's
uh a flag thrown by a coach or it's in
the window where there's an automatic
replay review
where you start has a huge influence on
where you finish
because are you overturning the ruling
that it wasn't a catch
and you need clear and obvious evidence
to overturn that or are you overturning
the ruling that it was a catch
and you need clear and obvious evidence
to overturn that and how many times
chris do we see a call
where whatever the ruling on the field
was
there isn't going to be clear and
obvious evidence to overturn it either
way
you can't overturn it because it's not
clear and obvious that that call was
wrong so
that adds another dynamic to it will the
replay assistant interject
and flip the standard that's what
happens because the replay assistant in
those cases is going to have the power
to set the framework for the replay
review
and make it harder to overturn the
ruling on the field so
that's a dynamic as well and let's hope
they had people in the room
who had the ability to have the
conversation we're having right now
about that because that's going to be a
very real dynamic
i mean do you think this is going to
slow the game down like i mean are we
gonna have moments here
of like you know this this replay
official
okay i mean yeah he's he's thinks it's
clear and obvious but he's gonna sit
there
and watch replays for a few seconds and
we're gonna have the the referees huddle
like we see them do like we were joking
about before
and they're gonna wait and give him a
little time now i mean is that what
they're doing there i i mean again i
just
to me it's the worst thing about replays
of course it slows the game down and
that was what was so bad a few years ago
with the past interference and
everything like that games were lasting
forever
and it's not a smooth fun watch that way
so i always worry about the clunkiness
of how this is operated
you know on a nfl sunday i i think that
the ball gets set for play the 42nd
clock rolls and he can do it then
there's a window of opportunity to to
communicate with the referee and they
can try to fix it and if there is
something that needs to be fixed
then that's when the game gets slowed
down now
i think one problem there one potential
complication would be
the replay assistant buzzes the referee
and tries to tell the referee
that maybe there was a mistake and the
referee doesn't agree
and the referee says you're just the
replay assistant keep your mouth shut
right
and i think that's part of the dynamic
as well how receptive
will the on field officials be to the
replay assistant
kind of sort of looking over their
shoulders that's why i've said
one of the reasons why i've said it
needs to be a full member of the crew
so it's not like we've got the officials
here
and johnny's overlooking yes he's always
overlooking us
now all of a sudden the replay
assistant's got power over us
that human factors come into play here
and again
when they talk this through when they
devise this when they discuss it
are they looking at it that way or are
they just stubborn and
short-sighted and narrow-minded and not
thinking it through the way that it
should be thought through
i don't know but based on some of the
rule changes we've seen in the past
you could argue that they're
short-sighted narrow-minded not thinking
it all through
no i mean yes it seems like some of this
stuff is kind of done on the fly at
times
or you know we just uh yeah there isn't
enough discussion
between really smart minds in the nfl
and everything like that
and taking into account all people to
get involved in these kind of
conversations i think when you talk
about this stuff
you know the whole league coaches gm's
everything that
you need all those think tanks there to
kind of go through this to flush it out
so i don't know we'll see how this goes
um it was my least favorite of the rule
changes that we had yesterday
well and i think it's the most
significant yeah i know it didn't go far
enough and this is a prime example every
once in a while i'll get this
pushback from folks why do you hate the
nfl why do you criticize the nfl
the the league office and the people who
are involved on these committees
whichever team they come from
competition committee this committee
that committee
they're stewards of the game they are
custodians of the power for now and it's
temporary it's going to be somebody else
in the future
and i think it's important for the
people who truly give a crap about the
game not just
now but in the future yeah and and folks
like us who've been following it for
years and intend to continue to do so
and we want what's best for it
i think it's important for people to ask
tough questions and offer criticism when
necessary
when the stewards of the game are
screwing the game up
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that now the people who are the
current stewards of the game that
we don't want to be criticized we don't
want to be questioned you're making our
lives more difficult
tough crap get it right then simple
solution you don't get criticized
if you don't screw up yeah well i mean i
mean yeah you said a lot of right things
there we're not doing it because we hate
the league that's for sure
it's exactly one thing it's actually the
exact opposite we love the game
and we always want it to be better it's
it's the exact opposite of that and yeah
we don't just you know
not going to just let them force feed us
you know new rules whatever and just go
oh okay great that was so smart that's
so amazing no
uh so all right we'll see where this
goes sky judge coming
off season 2022 at some point it's
coming and and one last point
it would be great for my digital
business
it would be great for this show it would
be great for anyone who
covers the league if for example there's
a huge scandal where a grand jury is
convened to find out
whether or not someone was on the take
when this horrible call happened that
there was no mechanism in place to fix
or
congress decides they're going to create
a federal agency that has
oversight of the nfl that would be a
great compelling story
i don't want that story it's not good
for the game
to have those things happen what's good
for the game is to get the calls right
so nfl you get a billion dollars over
the next five years
with your new tri-exclusive partnership
which makes no sense it's exclusive if
it's one they've got three
draftkings caesar's fanduel a billion
dollars for nothing just to make them
the official sports books of the nfl
spend that money to get the calls right
there's your money yeah and you don't
have to spend the full billion yeah but
that's where it is chris they're making
money for nothing with these deals
and gambling is going to cause cash to
fall from the sky
use that money to get the calls right or
it's going to cost you a hell of a lot
more in the long run
that is the primary message no you're
like they
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports